[Musique]
en java pour faire danser les corps et
chauffer la piste
les quelques 500 danseurs de ce bal
profit du répertoire de l' orchestre
doerig nouvelle pour tanguay une belle
occasion de faire se rapprocher les
coeurs nous dansons pratiquement tous
les dimanches c'est notre passion la
danse
cinq ans exactement ce qu'on s'est
rencontrés au bal de la saint-valentin
ici rencontrer le monsieur est une
invitée j'ai trouvé qu'elle dansait bien
j'ai trouvé qu'il dansait bien et donc
nous avons continué à danser au fil de
dimanche nos moyens ne nous permettent
pas de nous offrir un grand restaurant
mais bon
on se fait plaisir on en sait c'est une
façon de fêter là
n'a pas là l'anniversaire de notre
rencontre et la femme à long terme pour
les amoureux de la valse du tango ou du
chacha cette saint valentin sur la piste
de danse c'est une vraie célébration le
matin on se lève vacances à lèvres
sommet le plus haut possible et pour
viens danser on a l'habitude d'aller
donner dimanche de l'est au bal
nous avons cinquante deux années de
mariage encore et quand le rythme
s'accélère les têtes peuvent parfois
tourner un peu comme les robes le bal
c'est l'occasion aussi de se mettre sur
son 31
[Musique]
vous l'avez dit bonjour
on sait qu'il est important de la vie 50
super non j'ai connu au vrai
bal des rosaneri car on a toujours
souffert
lamonde
et
nous croit jamais ça
célébrer les amoureux c'est du sérieux
partager quelques pas de danse entre
passionnés aussi et finir la soirée avec
un tango quoi de plus beau pour nos
valentin
[Musique]